no I gotta record this this is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard
okay so we just watched this episode
he's like do you know who played this
guy I said no I said these things from
linking I said Nathan Lane he says no
clothes and he says that I said the pig
I didn't know the guys name he's like
who played the pig I said I don't know
he said Matthew Broderick I'm like no he
didn't play the friggin pig and he's
like I'm gonna look it up right now
checking the goddamn computer he is that
convinced that Matthew Broderick played
the pig do you really think he would
make that big an impression with this
performance actually I wanted to see
this I'm not that certain he played the
pig oh why are not telling me who we
played I keep asking you who he's
playing in you refuse to answer who's
the least interesting character in all
the movie all of them okay the least
though the Simba's father yeah really
Mufasa right right that's his name yeah
and fossa but okay take out war word the
hyenas oh they're pretty uninteresting I
know pop he's the Lion King why did you
just say that cuz I'm just I want to see
you I think he's really going there I
will fully admit that I did not know cuz
unlike someone I don't drool over Disney
but it's the freaking Matthew Broderick
as the as a funny character or okay it
was hilarious he was hilarious in
Godzilla not intentionally
exactly Lion King was pretty terrible
okay
it's a lot of fish who won okay that's
why I say like technical saying it who
would win remember via camera we should
dress your shirt by the way how come
you're not wearing an adventure time
shirt oh this is another one that my
daughter and my son found for me I
pooped today we aren't you just talk I
just did this food fight review we have
a lion where Malcolm just says I pooped
myself and we're just like like we got
to make a shirt out of that cuz you look
so happy with it too so it's just why
you wore that cuz now it's like dammit
it's practically taken yeah it is
well the first thing I said on Facebook
I think when a one
there was I wipe my ass because I find a
lot of it doesn't have fili no no that's
not Facebook that's Twitter get it right
well I don't have twitter at the time
okay now I do check me out on Twitter
guess what I never go on there are we
talking about oh yeah this is Adventure
Time yeah I guess we got talking about
no I wear this because I could see them
easily saying it on the show I'm waiting
for it no it becomes a gonna be like
they did say it in this episode line 25
uh-huh they're gonna be saying you're
taking too long to get to the review get
going let's think even the longer it's
talking about my shoes yeah they got
really messed up over the winter I don't
know just knowing you know I should
that's why they messed up or just get
these I know but these had the thing
where it's like okay I need these young
good thing no I know I need these little
dents in there because they kept
slipping groups all the time yeah just
really heavy I don't know what they're
called things on the bottom the little
bumpy thing look they're really fit
these are like really really deep so you
think we've been really enough that's so
deep it is deep we should think about
the deepness of the treads of your shoes
let's talk an even deeper deepness about
those that's most deepest I can go
that's yeah okay less deep let's talk
let's talk about saying we can go much
deeper into children's care to think my
shoes are much deeper I know I know it's
gonna be I can tear you is that's
nothing
okay so uh my wife says all right so who
way to win you're wearing sweatpants yes
okay the I give up pants swinging upon
my fence yeah I just promised Lee wanted
to distract even more cuz it's just I
don't care what anyone says about the
whole give up on life pants or anything
like that if there are actual people
call than that they're comfy so I I
choose to wear the man that okay we're
gonna stop dammit
talking about this damn episode um do
you ever take EDD medicine no Edie HD no
I probably should I'm like 90% positive
I have a DD I've never been tested for
it by probably a case in point boom
we're gonna talk about this dammit oh I
totally kick your ass I good welcome
Jeff egoic uh actually the first thing I
like I don't usually talk about but the
title car that love how the tile card is
just it's like this big yard's who would
win this beat that has just been itching
just sitting there yeah just just smile
on whatever you catch a little game yeah
he's got the little game and it's just
chill and it's like I like that it's
like this big epic title and even what
happens in it really I don't think I've
seen you on the show if Finn and Jake
like really fighting like really angry
at each other um and that's our the set
up they go up they see this giant farm
guy freaking hilarious design it it's a
bar it's a barn
I think it's so far but yeah it's a bar
named the farm oh there yeah okay see
for the longest time I thought his name
was the barn that's actually the farm
the farm yeah and it's really just a
barn serve on its side and this head
comes out it's also big just our flat to
sign the arms guy squeeze and he has
barnyard animals in a mansion
yeah as his bananas and it's pretty much
in this giant puddle of water and all
these people come to fight in and they
mostly have a great design that the
Train made me banana myself because that
every time it would talk you just see it
has no eyes no tongue it just has this
check or something for a mouth but it's
just opening up and whatever makes me
always it makes the little oh it killed
me every time that thing talk Oh bye
I didn't get it with a wrestler it
sounds like Randy Macho Man Savage but
no it's dana snyder Master Shake okay
yeah Jory caught that one so there your
representation women all over the world
is be women all over the world no dana
snyder
redeemed myself no you should probably
made it even worse she would know so I'm
sorry but they so if they be them they
just get whatever bragging legendary
stuff legendary status so they decide to
go train but Jake is too busy trying to
keep his status as third what highest
score on what's it called again
something castle was it go well is it go
I forgot Bugs Bunny's castle and so they
remade Bugs Bunny's crazy cats crazy
castle that was it um so Finn gets mad
and he just starts sir he takes his game
and destroys that Jake gets really mad
and most of it is just them fighting and
it's really good violence like it's
funny it's kind of brutal it's well
timed it's creative and it's most of the
episode it's kind of like a Tom and
Jerry episode of Tom and Jerry good like
more dad II think they wanted um and
finally at the end they're like oh no
they get knocked down they have a dream
with the dream warrior whose voice by
some I mean I impression on me
whatsoever I will fully call up my error
its voiced by Matthew Broderick who I
thought played the pig in Lion King
isn't gonna be as much fun oh I tell you
ruin your fun maybe a little bit
brutalized it's funny but you have a
Matthew project who it's like I heard
and I was like I didn't recognize who
was easily Matthew Broderick I was just
like oh yeah but he was supposed to
leave no way back right yeah okay that's
good choice i someone really dislikes
Matthew bro I'm sure he's a lovely guy
I'm sure he's really nice I saw Larry to
a foot somebody really Family Guy
no they let her on TV and she looks like
a foot
it I'm sure both of them are very nice
and lovely people oh I do like her for
that like Broderick in terms of acting
but you thought nepo so Louie he was
funny about uh but anyone I'm Louie is
funny so yeah so anyway he's there and
he just says the stuff about like you
know cheap cars and give up on my fancy
stuff it turns out he was getting the
strategy to how to defeat the barn they
defeat them and to get these nice little
medals and they're friends again and
it's it's just sort of a really fun
waste of time honestly but I really
liked it and like I said the there is a
right way to do slapstick a lot of
people are always like you know oh it's
just people even uture what's funny
about that
it's hilarious it is so funny it is so
funny
so they pretty much go and they win the
day and it's great and it's I don't know
it cracked me up because I love that
kind of stuff I sure but no I thought
was very fun I really like I said the
designs in this one we're really great
the creativity behind what Jake and
shape-shift into was great and I love it
when they're there fighting and then
they're they're kind of tired but
they're still angry at each other and I
like that because I think anyone that's
like got in a fight with a sibling or a
friend or something like that they've
gotten like weren't really into a fight
and sometimes it ends when you you take
a breath you're like yeah this is stupid
whatever but other times it's like
you're still angry and you're still
trying to hate the other person I just
like how they capture that like they're
tired but there's still kind of kind of
punching each other and whatever he's
like trying to walk away and they gets
his but big and smash but you could just
tell they're out of energy have you ever
seen old boy old boy movie yes no
nothing that's the whole Spike Lee no I
think no the original one of based on
the manga yes I know there's
one of the best fight sequences ever
takes place in this ultra cramped
hallway where it's one guy versus like
2030 guys and as the fights going along
he's giving like beaten up or he's
beating them up and they're just running
out of energy because it's all one take
all right and as you see them doing it
they're just like whoa one of the best
fight scenes ever when you said that
it's like yeah I never actually thought
about that with this one but yeah
they're fighting and they're just
getting tires it goes long cuz that's
what happens well especially in a
cartoon you don't think like anyone
whatever especially these two they have
so much energy uh but I think it
especially works here because they're
just so angry at you and I think you can
get you know you get a lot of energy
when it's fueled by some of your extreme
hate or extreme love whatever but it's
also drains you faster so it made sense
that they would be tired now let me ask
you something cuz this is something else
curious about I'm watching this and I
like that I thought was good when Finn
and Jake are fighting cuz they're really
fighting and you don't see that did you
like that it was over something pretty
legitimately stupid or would you have
liked if it sort of was something
heavier like a big I don't know
something like a big epic thing that
they kind of should be fighting about
well for me and I guess it's a little
different in this one they're fighting
fighting I as far as I know offhand and
I'm not taking into account like major
animates and stuff like that I'm saying
like overall kids cartoons cartoon anime
aimed at kids and on stuff big fights
that they have consist of push punch
done yeah like that's the big fight
scene wait you need an enemy right
between friends and suffrages yeah yeah
and it's it's usually over something
major or even if so for something minor
it's like kind of like this BS fight
that we're supposed to accept and go oh
yeah man who he punched him really hard
he knows what's going on this kind of
took it a step further where to me it
wasn't BS what they were fighting over
they both strongly believed in what was
going on you know it wasn't like oh you
stole my cookie and then in the end it
turned out that you didn't steal the
cookie
no Finn wanted to train Jake wanted to
play his game and neither of them wanted
to see each other's way they wanted
their own way and that's the way it was
you know what I'm saying though it's not
something like the stuff they would
fight over before like the outcome of
you know of their world or like a friend
or you know over somebody else or
something like that you know it's pretty
much bragging rights to fight this
person but they both they just take it
really really seriously I think it's
what most people take serious well are
you getting right yeah not just bragging
rights but like I think what's coming
down to the end of the world they're not
gonna go into a knock-down drag-out this
fight I mean not the end but you don't
need something that most people wanted
something like that major like they like
the same person or whatnot
I don't think it ever escalates to that
point I think these type of fights
happen over minor stupid things and
that's why you're also able to get over
10 times faster I mean - the more you
think about because what was watching is
something I really liked was the opening
when they're just sore hanging out and I
love when they're just hanging out and
that love when an episode can sort of
start like that and sometimes I almost
want to just go all the way through
again do nothing else um wolf in says it
too I love just having a bro time yeah
and I and I think that's especially I
yeah i think we guys especially there is
a sense of just getting away from
everything and either just being with
one other person or just alone or
something like that and i really like
their serve up there and they're not
talking to just sort of flying and fins
like this is cool you know and jakey
misses me like away from the lead users
just anyone like it's just cool just to
hang with someone like a best friend and
not have to do something not have to
have an obligation and i realized i
actually ties in better for when they
have to fight not because oh what a
contrast but i think you could kind of
argue that maybe something kind of was
building up like not knowledge in not a
legit hate for one another but just that
is sometimes when you're around a person
for so long that you always get along
it's just like at some point you're
gonna have some major confrontation i'm
even it's just other stuff or whatever
and usually I find that the people that
care about each other
the most strangely enough they'll be the
meanest too as well I mean because they
know it's like well I know this person
will come back I know I can I am this
person so I can be mean and sometimes
they let that get out of control and it
seems very much like people so don't let
it get out of control
yeah so they agree because that was the
one thing in the opening I'm certain
like because I really like that are like
okay it was just to serve bookend
Vincent not actually did kind of add up
I yeah I said the more I really thought
about him like yeah no I actually look
at it as a whole that actually did kind
of work I did like how the barn are
sorry the farm poops animals it's
usually the other way around you do you
eat the animal yeah does that mean he
eats feces and animals come out because
that would be safe eats bananas Parkash
yeah he's upright but maybe eat a banana
and animals come out possible possible
know one thing that I did like was or
one thing that I thought about what this
is who knows better how to fight each
other than Finn and Jake yeah Finn or
Jake is like this you know strange
oddity that can like morph into whatever
he wants but notice finn handles his own
against him hmm
why cuz Finn knows Jake's weaknesses if
you will I like him in the I move around
fast enough so he's hitting himself he
Jake you see very observant Saul you
have to top off his body and he'll
continue to punch himself if he knows
his mind so cuz I always served my phone
to it's like watching us I'm like well
it couldn't Jake just turned into a big
ambulance watching or something like
that but I think Finn knows what his
mind would go to next you know he's
probably gonna turn big alright so I had
to be quick I know he'll probably he
uses his fists first so I'll go around
to try to get his other hand or his high
or something like that so yeah it does
kind of make sense why he would have to
be pretty quick but at the same time
yeah I'm sure there's never a point
where it's like I want to kill week well
no I know thing either so I think that
probably plays a part oh yeah but it's
like okay there's the mud in the eye
that works
there's the biting of Jake like these
are dirty moves and all that stuff or
cheap moves but I like that so in the
days by the way - I was pretty much
playing dirty
I'm gonna say this really quickly since
when is a street fight anything
considered dirty out if they're playing
on water wasn't a streets exit well no
it's like okay let's say you're you're a
black belt in karate and we're in the
middle of the street
isn't that playing dirty you are ten
times a better fighter than I am no
matter what so what's the point of us
even fighting let's not fight I want to
fight
that's not no I'm gonna fight okay fight
breathe hey brick but do your butt in my
face
fisticuffs I don't want mr. kuffs
fisticuffs this is so because there's
not a gifs of you shaking your ass
there's never enough of that yes you got
a panther
oh my god it is I give a suckas life and
that's comedy